there are so many Easter eggs within
this film when you're watching what was
your favorite one to come by
oh my God there's so many of them this
is where I feel like we're not quite in
the glue
um do you have one I'm gonna go back to
the first one oh the first movie
here you go throw the bagel bagel
that's the best seed of the whole
between one and two taking it back yeah
uh dang I don't know that I could pick
just one uh there are about three that
came to mind and I I feel like I will do
anyone watching this the
um what's the word I'm looking for
hmm you're not gonna spoil it for that I
can't I refuse right but I feel like if
you know like if you know you know you
know what I'm saying you're gonna see it
you're gonna know there's three of them
that I really like